Donald Trump has been looking for a new
defense lawyer even as late as this
morning just hours before today's arrest
booking and arraignment this is
unbelievable stuff report from The
Washington Post Trump scrambles to find
lawyer before First Federal court
appearance what is happening Donald
Trump spent the day before his historic
appearance in federal court
scrambling to find a qualified Florida
lawyer willing to join his defense team
as he faces the Justice Department's
first prosecution of a former president
this is yesterday after touching down in
Miami Monday Trump spent the afternoon
interviewing prospective lawyers and
meeting with his legal team along with
other top advisors to discuss the case
in which as you know he's accused of
mishandling classified documents
obstruction Etc several prominent
Florida attorneys declined to take Trump
on as a client after two of the key
lawyers handling the document matter Jim
trustee and John Rowley resigned last
week a trump advisor said late Monday
Trump would be joined in court by Todd
Blanche an attorney handling his case in
New York as well as veteran Florida
litigator Christopher kais on the Troth
Central platform Trump said last week
Blanche would lead his defense team
along with a firm to be named later this
is not good this is very much not good
for Trump the article goes on to say
trustee and rowley's departure was
sudden and unexpected leaving Trump
jocking to identify a lawyer ahead of
today's appearance in federal court
where rules require practicing attorneys
to be members in good standing of the
Florida bar or be sponsored by one
before appearing kais led the search for
a lawyer and cast a seemingly wide net
he declined to comment the 11th Hour
flurry to hire a seasoned trial attorney
was a familiar dance for Trump who has
had difficulty hiring and keeping
lawyers over the course of federal and
state investigations disagreements over
legal strategy hindered this search for
new defense attorneys this is wild wild
stuff that this is unbelievable in a
normal World attorneys would be
qualified attorneys would be falling all
over themselves to defend a former
president in an unprecedented situation
but they are probably becoming aware
that when you tell Trump uncomfortable
truths like the indictment is strong or
mistakes have been made up until now and
we are now digging out or you might have
to plea in some way
Trump probably loses his mind it's
unclear whether these lawyers would even
be able to get paid so in a sense in a
situation where lawyers should be
desperate to work with Trump
it's fascinating that there are even
lawyers still willing to represent Trump
and it's probably a small subset of
people who are like smart enough to pass
the bar
but not clever enough to realize that
working with Trump in this capacity is
an impossibility because of uh the
difficulties in both collecting payment
and getting Trump to actually do what
you suggest that he does and we've
talked before about Maga really means
making attorneys get attorneys that's
been a theme as well the smartest
possible interpretation of this entire
lawyer thing would be Trump is staging a
difficulty in finding lawyers as a delay
tactic to continually be able to have
lawyers say to a court hey I was just
brought on I need a delay in order to
familiarize myself with the facts of the
case and then you switch again and again
and again there is that's that's the
most generous interpretation there is
absolutely no evidence that that's
actually what's going on this is a wild
situation where Trump is struggling to
find lawyers even hours before today's
court appearance will be live for the
arraignment and the arrest and the
entire thing on YouTube twitch and
Facebook and I hope you'll join me here
is the perfect Father's Day gift get him
a Wi-Fi connected digital picture frame
from Aura our sponsor Aura has been
named the number one best digital
picture frame by wire cutter the
strategist and wired this is not one of
these early 2000s picture frames there's
no USB or SD cards and you get free
unlimited storage and you can instantly
frame photos and videos from any device
anywhere in the world I have several of
these I got my dad one and so now I take
pictures of the baby load them into his
or a frame and they show up and
everybody loves it you know it's no more
of these having to bring a slideshow
When I visit I just put the pictures
right in the frame I'm really glad I got
him one of these and right now Aura has
a great deal for Father's Day go to
auraframes.com Pacman
use the code Pacman to get thirty
dollars off plus free shipping this deal
ends June 18th so don't wait terms and
conditions apply the link is down below